Aquí está declarando con todo el corazón, con lágrimas en los ojos, a frente de mis
hijas, mis yernos, mis nietos. Lástima que no está en presencia mi testigo mío. ¿Cómo
sobrevivimos todo eso? Ese es mi testigo. Él no con diferencia. Dios podía contestar
los ángeles. No, ella ahorita no puede decir. No puede usted decir la cosa. Las palabras
que en este momento yo estoy hablando, ella está oyendo.
Él se dijo David a Mélagre.
Él caminó con los más grandes enemigos que están en camino.
Sobreviví conmigo junto. Luchado conmigo junto. Aquí tengo yo testigos, mis hijas,
mis yernos, mis nietos, y puede ser que alguna vez que haya explicado esa es la historia.
Es mi testigo que yo declaro hoy en ocho horas.
Segundo. Es. ¿Qué significa?
Biyad abuso, biyad malajem, biyad sal, biyad jazoku.
Biyad jazoku significa que uno tiene que estar en la vida con mano fuerte.
Uno tiene que estar decidido para bueno y para malo.
David a Mélagre dijo así.
Hombre muy sufrido, David a Mélagre.
Él en su historia dice que tenía mucho dolor mandar a su general a frente de la guerra.
La historia dice de ver.
Él se fue y mandado la seda a la mujer de Jervillos.
Yo puedo explicarle a usted muchas cosas de esto.
Te voy a decir una última frase.
En la historia de nosotros se llama el gran sabio Abakibar.
Era un gran sabio.
Él se casó con una muchacha muy rica.
Él le puso condición a su mujer.
Yo no entiendo Talmud nada y yo no sé leer Talmud nada.
Yo me quiero irme en el mundo para estudiar.
Era un hombre muy inteligente.
En veintidós años él fundió veinticuatro estudiantes.
Y que se viene Talmud, como todo en la historia se está hablando del gran sabio Abakibar.
Abakibar está reconocido en el mundo.
Yo oigo su gente allá que tiene bien pensar esa palabra que era Abakibar.
Saló voz en su edad de él.
Que aquí está regresando un gran sabio con veinticuatro estudiantes.
Imagínate como era el recibimiento.
La señora de él era tan pobre que no tenía zapatos.
Entonces todo el mundo, cuando él llegó con veinticuatro estudiantes,
se puso trapos en su pie y entre gente.
Entonces ella no sabía que era su esposa Abakibar.
Se quiso acercar a ver a ese gran sabio.
Entonces doyando, se empujaron.
¡Ey, que no se acerca!
Entonces dijo así, como usted dijo, con el dedo así.
¡Respeto!
Gracias de esta mujer que está frente a mí.
Con trapos en pie.
Gracias a ella.
Dios el sabio Abakibar es mi esposo.
Y usted también es mi esposo.
Esa es la declaración mía.
Cuando uno se casa, uno no sabe qué puede presentar la vida.
La vida es muy redonda.
No siempre hay tener respeto a su marido y marido respeto a su mujer.
Aquí hay dicho que tengo mucho que explicarle.
Usted está muy apurado.
Déjame que va.
Como usted es religioso.
Entonces le estoy explicando qué es lo mío.
Señorita, yo creo que su familia quiere decirle algo.
Ahorita tienen palabras.
Ellos que puedan hablar, cada uno que quiera.
Amén.
Está libre ahorita.
Las personas que quieran intervenir tienen derecho.
Bueno, yo como yerno mayor voy a tomar la palabra.
Con el permiso de los familiares.
Yo quiero hacer un reconocimiento a la Fundación Shoah y a Spielberger.
Que nos demuestra en estos momentos que estamos viviendo en el mundo.
La importancia de esta actividad.
Cuando un juez italiano, el juez Chistelli.
Absuelve a un criminal de guerra, a un asesino nazi.
Como ha sido Pritzker.
De manera que esta actividad que ustedes están realizando.
Será siempre actualizada y siempre importante.
Y quiero que me contacten por si es necesario que yo ofrezca una colaboración.
Que los ayude a continuar en este trabajo.
Bueno, yo quiero decir algo un poco en continuación del mismo pensamiento.
Que mi papá acaba de decir.
De que toda esta historia que ustedes grabaron hoy.
Para gran parte de la familia.
Nosotros fuimos al abuelo a Polonia.
Y recorrimos la ruta de su vida en Polonia hasta el año 44.
43, 93.
Fuimos en el 93, pero recorrimos la historia de su vida hasta el 46.
En Polonia en realidad.
Ahí fue la fecha que ganó.
Aunque él hizo lo contrario.
Y para nosotros es una historia muy vívida.
Y lo que no se quiere es que esta historia sea dentro de dos generaciones.
La historia del abuelo o del abuelo.
Es algo que se permanezca durante el tiempo.
Y creo que es un esfuerzo muy consono con la estructura de la cultura judía.
Del pueblo judío.
De que el Talmud empezó como una recopilación de leyes y costumbres.
Se convirtió en un código que hasta en los códigos napolónicos se encuentra incluido.
Y este tipo de historia debe pasar de generación en generación.
Aunque sea triste y duro recordarlo.
Que este es un evento que debe ser recordado al mismo tiempo con alegría.
Al mismo tiempo con tristeza y respeto.
Y si quiero hacer eco lo que dice mi papá.
De elogiar los esfuerzos de la Fundación de Permanecer.
Este recuerdo de medida que pasa el tiempo.
De mantener estos testimonios bastante difíciles para los testigos.
De expresar porque de cierta manera es como revolver un poco un pasado bastante nebuloso.
Y difícil.
Y que muchos hubiesen preferido olvidar y no pensar jamás en eso.
Y que muchos han logrado sobrevivir.
Y vivir con ello a lo largo de su vida.
Aunque todos ellos han sufrido por esto a lo largo de su vida.
Pero sí es importante recordarlo esto.
Este es un evento de la significación para cada familia.
Como es romper la copa y el matrimonio.
Porque siempre hay que recordarse lo que pasó en el pueblo judío.
De donde venimos y hacia donde vamos.
Y la verdad es que tengo muchas ganas de ver el traceto.
Una vez que pueda ser visto por todos los que no estuvimos aquí hoy.
Creo que me queda bien.
Le tengo que decir una sola cosa.
Ah, eso es todo.
Acá es leyendo.
Mira, Yuli.
Ellos hablaron de todo lo que significa para ellos una historia.
Pero yo quiero hablar lo que significó para mí.
Primero una profunda tristeza.
Cuando ya uno tiene sentido de la conciencia de lo que es la vida.
Lo que una pareja joven que se está casando.
Comienza la guerra.
En donde se ven frustradas todas sus ilusiones, los proyectos de vida.
Donde se ve destruidas familias, ideas.
Donde uno se cuestiona la vida.
Cuando yo era chiquita.
Los cuentos envidiaban mucho a las niñas que tenían abuelos.
Que tenían tíos.
Los cuentos de hadas de mi familia eran siempre como oscuros.
Cuando las fiestas judías, que entendía que las fiestas de las personas no judías eran alegres.
Las mías siempre eran tristes.
Porque no se contaban cosas.
A los niños no se les podía contar cosas.
Pasa el tiempo y uno va siendo adolescente.
Va oyendo y va concatenando todas esas cosas.
Pero no las entiende.
A través de la vida que me ha tocado vivir.
Y a través de mi profesión.
Todavía sigo sin entenderla.